hi I'm Matt Welch editor-in-chief of
Reason magazine and author of McCain the
myth of a maverick we're outside the XL
Center on the last day of the Republican
convention and the buzz in the air is
still from last night's speech of vice
presidential nominee Sarah Palin but
last night was also something else
inside the center it was supposed to be
the evening in which Republicans talked
about reform and yet did you ever really
hear anybody talk about the signature
pieces of reform that John McCain has
been associated with no you really
didn't campaign finance reform is to
this convention what the surge was to
the Democratic convention the great
thing that shall go unmentioned it's of
course very unpopular among Republicans
and and at this point after five years
or so of implementation I don't think
anybody can really say that it had a
transcendent effects on our system that
John McCain had promised back then you
also didn't hear much about immigration
reform for the important reason that
it's deeply unpopular among Republicans
and that to failed the other striking
thing last night was the discussion
about economics and free-market policies
such as it was as a friends of mine have
said who were on the Left who supported
Ron Paul the thing they liked about him
is that at least he reminded them of
what Republicans used to be like if you
were listening to the sort of economic
prescriptions inside the building last
night you have no idea what Republicans
stand for there was talk of repopulating
the heartland of having food security so
that we're growing our all our own food
here there was talk of restoring jobs in
the Rust Belt in Michigan through sort
of industrial policies these are not the
policies of a limited governments
republican party and in fact reflect the
fact that John McCain at the top of the
ticket has in his own words never really
been that interested or knowledgeable
about economics and at this point is
just doing and saying what he thinks he
needs to in order to win an election for
recent TV I am Matt Welch